tis the season for porch pirates a sad
reality especially during the holidays
one man actually caught his packaged
thieves on camera and confronted them
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
live in the 8 news now backyard with the
story in madison
this all happened in henderson correct
yeah that's correct and one man made it
his mission to catch the culprits but
what he found
was even more surprising but that like
really lit a fire under me i was like
now not only are these people stealing
from me they're stealing from the
community and now like a kid's health is
at risk matt dolan and his wife never
thought something like this would happen
to them
in their gated community multiple
packages stolen within a week
and it turns out they weren't alone his
neighbors also getting notified that
their packages had been delivered but
there was nothing to show for it
one of those packages stolen being baby
medicine for a newborn
matt knew he had to do something so he
left a phony package in front of his
door to see if he could catch the
culprit in the act
and on friday it finally happened within
two minutes
a little kid probably like 11 12 years
old
and an older man walk by and i know
they're from the the house down the
block
and they they walk right by here and uh
they stop they look at the package and
then they keep walking
and they walked out of my line of sight
i realized
he's checking to see if i'm in the
backyard so they disappear for like five
seconds they see i'm not back there
and i hear the guy say grab it matt got
all of this on video
and eventually confronted the man and
the little kid turns out the kid was the
man's nephew and they lived a couple
doors down
eventually they did admit okay we took
this stuff
and so the guy waited outside the kid
went inside and he brings out eight
packages of medicine it's hard for
everyone right now like
i'm not working right now so going
around stealing packages and making a
buck i mean
you're hurting other people
a police report was filed but charges
were never filed they decided to not go
that route
all of the items that were never
returned were eventually paid for
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now